[Music]
[Music]
ah
yes amanda lakerie i'd know that brow
anywhere here's the bounty you requested
excellent mid-season bounties are quite
valuable
we will add him to the collection the
freezing process has improved over the
years
somewhat the los angeles super team is
now complete
not quite there's one more asset i need
from your home planet
naboo orleans yes there is a new threat
to our empire there
a child as the future of basketball he
belongs in a big market
perhaps you should bring the rondo 9. no
the child's defenders will just sag off
the rondo and double me in the paint
[Music]
i'm here for the child there's three of
us
and one of you do you really think
you're as strong as three men
and three draft picks
so long amanda lakerin
keep shooting like that they'll make you
a stormtrooper
[Music]
you're the future of basketball i guess
you're gonna move a lot of merch
well let's go
we've gotta get you below 270.
welcome back to space sports talk our
top story
shocking revelations about former nba
great obi-wan wallace
obi-wan wallace i wonder if he means old
ben wallace
[Music]
leaving there is for your own good
basketball once flourished everywhere
but that was before the rise of the
super team i was there for the slaughter
of my people
in the 2012 2013 2014 2015 2016
2017 2018 and 2019 seasons
i had no choice but to flee with 18
months still on my contract
this is the way
it's the duke blue devils they want you
back for three more years
hold on kid kid
[Music]
we lost them how did you do that i've
never seen a ship cut so hard that it
tore apart its own landing gear
i guess you are special too special for
lebron to banish you to the three-point
line
i can't take you to him there's only one
place to go
there is no more basketball here you'll
be safe
i wouldn't count on it the rondo 9 put a
tracking device
on your ship damn it i didn't search my
ship for tropes
now stand at the three-point line while
i talk to the child
i won't let you have him i understand
your conflict
i too once felt the pull of market guilt
and went back to my home planet
but all stars belong in los angeles
we couldn't agree more we also left
small markets
but there's two super teams on your
planet lebron
and we want the child
come to the clippers my son here i am
dad
oh not you he should join the golden
empire
now mate he should join the process boy
kitty wink
you want to be part of the process the
child isn't going with any of you
get out of here papovitch no the child
can succeed anywhere
i thrived for decades in the barren
deserts of san antoine
enough for years you tried to sell me on
that small
market crap
oh i'm out for five games maybe a season
run
and take the child with you there's too
many of them
we can't escape yes we can i'll coach
the rondo 9.
what if you try to coach a rondo 9 it
self-destructs
rondo 9 play within the offense
initiating
self-destruct run
don't worry i'm sure popovich will come
back as a ghost
so kid where should we go now
home but you can't win there
[Music]
small market make big i will
i am the real chris paul man this guy
even follows me into space
don't fall for mind tricks you want the
real deal especially when it comes to
home and auto insurance
[Music]
[Applause]
you